[Musique]
le rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique à composante essentielle du
grand sampler vous pas pays en chance le
rdr qui a taclé alfred marie-jeanne lors
de la plénière de jeudi et vendredi
derniers tacler et le terme semble fred
faible bonjour marie france toul bonjour
morisien le toyboy jour aux auditeurs et
auditrices de matinée vous êtes la
secrétaire général adjoint du rdr ce qui
a mis le feu aux poudres une divergence
de vues entre le fait de donner la
parole aux délégations syndicales ou pas
alfred magique où marie-jeanne ne le
souhaitait pas que la devise oui et on
connaît la suite
c'est juste une simple divergence de vue
sur un point on s'est beaucoup plus que
cela à marie-france poule alors il faut
dire que c'est une divergence
alors que la qualifiée de simple ou de
pas simple bon nous verrons par la suite
mais toujours est il que je crois qu'il
est important de rappeler que le
rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique est une composante du grand
ensemble et pour ben pays en chance et
on pense souvent du grand ensemble et
prom a payé en chance et on oublie
qu'avant il y a eu le grand semblait et
que pour pouvoir justement arrivé au
second tour il a fallu avoir le ndm avec
avec les différents partis de patriotes
donc aujourd'hui le mdm considère qu'il
a toute sa place et qu'il a tout ça sa
liberté pour s'exprimer parce que
aujourd'hui rassemblement ne veut pas
dire que les partis politiques perdent
leur identité
le rdr a contribué largement à la
victoire puisqu'il faut savoir et ça on
l'oubli que le rdm a été le deuxième
financeur de la campagne donc ce n'est
pas rien et je crois que ce qui a
surtout était important pour le rdm là
lors de cette plénière c'est de faire
valoir et de mettre en avant ses valeurs
des valeurs au niveau de la démocratie
mais aussi des valeurs que nous
considérons qu'il est important pour
nous de placer l'homme au coeur de nos
préoccupations au coeur de notre
politique la charge de belfort birota
été cinglante au rdr monnaies des
démocrates on s'est battu pour un idéal
et ce n'est pas pour voir tout cela
détruit à cause il l'a dit de nego crac
de notes au crac et le doigt pointé vers
le président du conseil exécutif c'est
plus qu'une petite brèche à ça au jour
d'aujourd'hui comme je les dis nous
avons signé un accord
nous avons signé un accord est utile et
pour un large mouvement unitaire et
populaires et dans ceux dont ce document
il y avait un certain nombre de deux
prérogatives 1 qui avait été actée pour
le temps au niveau du président du
conseil de l'exécutif que celui de
l'assemblée
si aujourd'hui on constate que beaucoup
de ces décès engagements qui avaient été
pris vis-à-vis du président de
l'assemblée ne sont pas respectés nous
et en deuxième on peut on peut on peut
passer là dessus par contre quand il
s'agit de l'intérêt général
quand il s'agit de la démocratie il est
très difficile pour nous de passer outre
je veux simplement le voulions que dans
le document que nous avons signé il
était noté que les organisations les
charges donc alfred marie jeanne et
claude lise également de garantir le
fonctionnement démocratique de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
afin de favoriser la libre expression de
toutes les sensibilités politiques tant
de la majorité que de l'opposition ce
n'est plus le cas donc à partir de ce
moment ce n'est plus le cas marie-france
ce que je veux dire que pour nous il est
fondamental que cette règle soit
respectée alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut le
dire ce matin
marie-france tools est ce que le rdm a
pris des distances avec le mime plus
particulièrement le rdm ac en plus que
jamais ses valeurs du mois c'est même
plus que jamais avait pris des distances
avec le mime après ce qui s'est passé
jeudi et vendredi mais que le prendre
des distances
c'est à dire aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une dans un contrat de gestion nous
avons signé un contrat de gestion
nous avons une responsabilité vis-à-vis
de la population pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions porter un projet sur
lequel nous sommes tous d'accord sur ce
projet néanmoins néanmoins dans ce
projet il y à un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles nous ne pouvons
pas déroger c'est à dire le respect de
la démocratie et le fait aussi de faire
en sorte de garantir comment dirais-je
notamment le dialogue social dans la
collectivité c'est fondamental pour nous
mêmes au sein du mime
on se souvient des votes de joie
scharbook étiez de christiane
bourrasques était différent quand même
de ceux de claude lise de belfort birota
et de raphaël martin il faudra faire un
état des lieux au sein même de votre
formation politique
je crois que tous les partis politiques
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de pensée unique
et on voit bien que dans les partis il
ya même sept
on voit bien que les partis politiques
aujourd'hui on n'a plus cette comment
dirais-je cette obéissance ont fait
cette discipline de parti et comme tous
les pentes il est en dm et ben il n'est
pas une fait pas il est bien différente
donc le ndm louis qui a notamment aidé à
matignon fait qu'ils n'ont pas suivi qui
ont fait qu'ils ont pris leur décision
la glace rmc cet élu vous avez quand
même de quoi peser dans le jeu peser
dans le game qu'est ce que vous allez
décider là maintenant pour pouvoir
mettre les points sur les i pour pouvoir
harmoniser une philosophie idéal de
fonctionnement au sein même du père dit
m
parce qu'il va falloir se positionner
maintenant par rapport aux grands
ensembles et met aujourd'hui en france
aujourd'hui je répète je pense que le
secrétaire général et nous tous nous
avons comme vous et vu qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de camarades qui n'ont
pas
fait ce même choix on respecte la
liberté des uns et des autres on
respecte aussi les prises de position de
ceux qui sont dans notre majorité et je
crois que nous aurons puisqu'il est
prévu un séminaire nous allons discuter
de la ligne du parti aurait deux ans et
demi après l'avènement du grand ensemble
et booba péan chance on peut dire que ça
vole en éclats lenny loris tu de côté
qui disent on ne comprend pas ce qui
nous arrive mais pourquoi il ya mon
plaisir de l'autre côté qui dénonce une
insuffisance de l'action politique et de
l'argent mis sur la table pour lancer la
machine en martinique mais qui se
présente comme étant le royaliste et
puis le rdm dont le secrétaire général
ne cache plus son exaspération du mode
de fonctionnement de l'assemblée
vous savez ce que disent les gens ce
qu'ont dit les martiniquais au cours du
week-end
on a encore trois ans à tenir plus de
trois ans à venir dans cette ambiance je
crois que il y a effectivement certain
nombre de choses et notamment les points
que je viens de souligner chez lesquels
ils étaient pas en temps de revenir et
de souligner notamment le respect de la
démocratie les valeurs faire en sorte
que l'homme soit vraiment au coeur de
nomination vokoun mais alors au japon
suit vous connaissez le jazz aussi je
pense et ça c'est ça c'est aussi une
réalité qu'il y ait un certain nombre de
choses parce qu'on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas non plus avec cette cesser ces
divergences mettre tout de côté puisque
on voit bien on voit bien que les
décisions de la fed décision leurs
points forts sont à voter de manière une
soeur global recession de la police au
delà sur beaucoup de dossiers les élus
martiniquais se retrouve maintenant
c'est un s'étonne c'est une comment
dirais-je c'est un point fondamental et
si ça a pris autant de temps alors moi
je rappelle que je n'étais pas là mais
je pense que c'est ça un rien de temps
c'est parce que peut-être que certains
n'ont pas très bien compris la prise de
position du président de l'assemblée
parce qu'il ne s'agissait nullement
nullement de remettre en cause les
prérogatives du président du conseil
exécutif il ne s'agissait pas d'eux
réfléchir sur la pertinence de la
décision du président du conseil
exécutif mais bien de respecter nos
valeurs
et ça ce sont des valeurs qui sont
fortes les chaînes ard m marie-france
sol dans toute cette agitation a quand
même vu les élus dans ce sens pour une
martinique nouvelle qui applaudissait
claude lise et de la ce a ouvert la
semaine sorte de boîte de pandore tous
les fantômes j'ai vu des élevé d'enfants
pour une martinique nouvelle applaudir
le président du conseil exécutif est
aussi un jallet déjà vu alors que
rappeur rapprochement j'ai un berger m
comme certains ont pu le dire au cours
du week end vous avez entendu ça aussi
alors je trouve que c'est vraiment
triste d'entendre de tels propos après
les luttes et les batailles que nous
avons menées côte à côte et on oublie
que les batailles des tours d'essai nous
sommes tous à élus de l'assemblée ou de
l'exécutif ah si c'est parce qu'à un
moment donné nous avons été solidaires
nous nous sommes battus ensemble côte à
côte et que ce sont ces divergences
d'opinion de voix qui se sont élevées
qui ont fait que nous avons pu gagner
nous nous sommes battus ensemble côte à
côte nous avons mené des batailles très
dur et c'est vraiment essentiel que ça à
fond puisse retenir cela merci marie
france au secrétaire générale adjointe
du rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique bonne journée